to the corner fala for La broken up H ofer Bor
strand gets a little help from gourd Trevor Moore
goes to work fiala in tight stopped by dord it's
a scramble the LA Kings this is where they won
the board battle and then all of a sudden Here
Comes fiala not looking to pass the they play
catch to the slot with J now more fala back for
England Andreas England Jordan Spence fala out in
front of wedge is blocked more shot Den by dord
checked by Spence to the wall Shore now Yamamoto
away from England holding on to it he saucers the
pass dun shot blocked Larson gets after it right
in to the blue they score Adam Larson the big cat
comes calling early as it trickles by K talot and
the Kraken are off and running the fourth line
again gets the job done he gets it he's going
to make a stick handle just like M did now if you
ask lar JT says you know what that's what I try
to do fake the shots and it let it go between
the legs of c telet and the Kraken with a one-
nothing lead and you got to give credit to the
fourth on you see out front it's Belmar in the
battle that's where you want that line to work JT
you want that citar line to have to play 200 feet
away from Joey Arthur cev with a shot picking
cherri's Joey dord Kua only has 12 points he's
a minus four on a team that scores quite a bit
England with a shot sticked Along by dord but
I I believe since he came will borgan has played
like he did last year and he was flat out awesome
the Kraken need him to keep playing that way
stick save dord remember the car the Bol now
it's kicked out by dord it had Corinthian leather
look that up JT now bi blocked a chance for more
he scores Trevor Moore the top goal getter
for the Los Angeles Kings comes through 627
left in the first period we're tied could not
get a handle of the puck and Advance it out of
the zone and all of a sudden La goes to work
over skate two players go to one two different
times and then Here Comes Trevor more with a
beautiful forehand backhand from our MC delivery
slow-mo dowy now moves it back for Adrien Kee
he'll navigate through the middle supported a
bit by Quinton Byfield who has it now he'll
Advance they score banged home by anre
Kopitar he has goals and backto back games 244
left in the second period it's a power play goal
the Kings by one he finds this Puck to crack
it were okay but unfortunately alexc loses his
Edge there's copar gets outside goes
to the net by Fields got this Puck and
I don't think gour or Larson knew that kopar 15
times big scramble dor takes away the lower
portion well that is true he he does look HEI
looks good all the time so do you blocker saved
to court England oh the cross the crossbar
you never left okay thing here like a pinball
machine square off of the crossbar NBI Joey
here's a chance for Trevor Moore shut down
Joey Dort outstanding recovery guarded by by
copar Evans up top now mccan Evans one more
time York Strand stretches out in front tipped
on denied by talit gourd had the tip Evans in
control he'll get it back from Jared mccan York
Strand on this side now looks over coverage to
the line wiberg mccan Evans holding on to it bork
stram with a shot he scores F the maestro Oliver
Bor strand on the power play but cracken have
tied it it almost seemed like it was a matter
of time moving the puck around different looks
Johnny as you brilliant picked up Oliver over
on the other side the net front Presence by Yanni
and webert working mean from side to side Evans
with the perfect pass and look at that reaction
the Maestro with a big Power Play goal which is
forced overtime and forced the shootout oneon-one
with Cam Talbot great stop by the Los Angeles
goenda makes a quick little fake and then
just not able to elevate the Trevor Moore
leads La in terms of goals he scored his 14th
of the Season earlier tonight shooter number
one quickly in snare by dor option is to go for
a quick shot trying to get it up over the glove
Joey just standing right at the top Tomas Tatar
what a moment here stopped by K talut where they
just did not execute the shot there's room up top
you make that same move you go forehand here Luke
duah in the two hole for Todd mclen stopped by 35
most times when a lefty comes down on the right
side like this looking for that low blocker shot
Joey dord reads the play the Kraken f one shootout
The Cider this season Kyler Yamamoto has it make
it to a Spoke can Special by Kyler Yamamoto what'
we say a little bit earlier about not elevating
the puck he elevates it just enough over the p
he swoops in he scores Adrien kempe will extend
the shootout Kee comes in and he throws a hard
fake gets Joey to bite that opens up the room
and Joey still almost makes the save but he's
able to elevate it first crack added is Alex
wenberg a stutter step and a stick save by
talbat oh goodness an Kopitar the
future Hall of Famer it's in his
hands stopped goal line stand Joey
dord that's about as close as it gets
the overhead is going to be a perfect
view here off the toe and that puff
just sits see Devon Sher go forehand
backhand but he's going to go over onto
this for hand side sure tal got a piece
of [Applause] it oh just off the pad
it looked like Jared mccan round number
six shut [Applause] down just right
here just doesn't quite hit his shot
right there the legs get closed
the stick is in the position as
well well an empty net talit just on the
other side a heck of a move Trevor Lewis
on the cord he scores forehand backand
Joey just misses the Poke check ninth
round stick save cam talet let's
see elevates it quickly and based on this is Carl
grundstrom he scores the LA Kings
it takes nine rounds they win the
shootout